تشير مجموعة متزايدة من الأبحاث في كل من
البشر والحيوانات إلى أن
النوم المضطرب يؤدي إلى مستويات أعلى
من البروتينات المرتبطة بمرض الزهايمر في
الدماغ ، وقد
أظهرت العديد من الدراسات التي أجريت على البشر وواحدة على
الفئران وجود صلة بين
اضطراب النوم المزمن
وترسب لويحات الأميلويد في
الدماغ  هذه هي أول
مرحلة ما قبل السريرية معروفة لمرض الزهايمر الآن ،
دراسة نُشرت في مجلة
Neurology تضيف إلى هذه الهيئة من
العلماء الذين قاموا بفحص ما يزيد قليلاً عن 100 من
البالغين الأصحاء معرفيًا
بمتوسط عمر 63 عامًا ، ودرسوا على وجه التحديد ال
لاقة بين نو
ية نوم المشاركين ومستوياتها.  من
البروتينات والعلامات المختلفة في
السائل النخاعي وجد الباحثون
أن الأشخاص الذين يعانون من اضطراب النوم كانوا
أكثر عرضة لإظهار دليل على
تلف خلايا الدماغ إلى جانب الالتهاب
وتلف بروتينات الدماغ المسؤولة عن
استقرار الخلايا وهيكلها ،
قال المؤلف المشارك في الدراسة إن أبحاثهم تتوافق
مع  فكرة أن قلة النوم يمكن أن
ت  الإسهام في تراكم
البروتينات المرتبطة بمرض الزهايمر في
الدماغ ، وآمل أن يؤدي البحث
إلى فرص للتدخل
المبكر في اللحظة الصحية الحالية ، أنا كيم
هاتشرسون